joining us now a guy that's won one of
these things a hall of famer both the
college and the pro level
he's a coach he's a broadcaster he i
don't know if there's any hat that the
great
rod woodson has not worn and a former
colleague at nfl network
as well how are you rod woodson
what's going on there thanks for having
me on there is no way this is a bad game
right
no i mean if it's if i was a
paying customer and going to the super
bowl this is the one i don't want to go
to
uh i think it's going to be a close game
i think you can make an argument
for both teams to win and that's why
when you make that type of army and then
it always comes out
okay if this this happens this happens
that they gonna win if this this this
and this happens they're gonna win
that's the type of game you wanna watch
what has to happen for the bucks to win
i know that sounds absurd because they
have tom brady
right but the the idea that the chiefs
can explode at any moment
i think probably hangs over all four
quarters
so rod is a defensive guy what do they
have to do to make sure that doesn't
happen
well you know you know go back to the
last the first game that they had
in in november they really didn't have a
running game
and i think you know the way lena
fournette was
is running the ball now as of late and
jones is running the ball
if they can run the ball and steal play
action pass
use gronk use those big receivers and
goblin and evans
and even the tight end uh the other
tight end and break
you have some players and you know
if they can do that consistently run the
football
that's going to slow them down that's
going to keep the homes and that
explosive offense on the sideline you
can't score when you're on the sideline
and at the end i think todd bowles
defense
he has to find a way where he's been
doing a really good job he did a really
good job so far in the postseason to
mixing it up when he was going to make
pressure
uh when he was going to place a man who
is going to play a little soft zone
and that secondary played pretty good
football the first game
and i wouldn't be surprised they do it
again but if they can
play their best game running the
football todd bowles getting after my
homes
not playing a lot of man-to-man because
that's one thing that you're kind of
want to stay away from when you play
against my home for that speed that they
have on that offense
and they can get that pressure with the
front four of the bucks defense
then they have a great opportunity and
tom brady has a great opportunity to get
his seventh
super bowl ring talking to the great rod
woodson hall of famer on the field and a
great coach as well when he wore that
hat
rod you mentioned get to mahomes with
four
look the numbers tell you you don't
blitz him he kills you every time
but your instinct i would have to think
as a defender is go after the guy
right so how do you resist the urge
to find ways to heat them up
well let's just go back to the one game
they lost this year
all right when you go back and watch
that game and the
the raiders beat them in the first
quarter and a half the raiders played a
lot of man-to-man
and they were getting tore up they were
getting
just bombed and you know at halftime
they did a tremendous job and they
changed the game plan they went to more
zone and they were getting pressure with
their front four
doing some games up front and cosby did
a great job on the edges on
on his own of getting pressure to the
back behind there and getting pressure
on the homes
and they won that game and to me when
you play against them
because it's one thing that you don't
want to do with them when you have
tyreek hill
when you have a hard man we you just
said a little while ago the robin has
been cleared to play
we haven't even talked about sami you
know so you have so many and then we
didn't talk about
the best tight end in the national
football league and travels kelsey
when they have those type of weapons you
don't want to play a lot of man-to-man
because they can take those shots down
the field if you can keep everything in
front of you
if you can do that that that just bodes
well for your football team to win those
type of games
if you can do all those things which is
kind of easier said than done
with the chiefs talking to the hall of
famer rod woodson it's it's just absurd
right like we did this on nfl network
all year and listen we're feeding the
beast and it's a long season and you're
trying to keep it interesting every week
but
you know we had that stretch in the
second half of the season man are we
concerned
that the chiefs are playing all these
close games they're playing one
possession games
they're susceptible aren't they and then
you step back and you go
like you just said well the one game
they lost yeah if you throw out week 17
and chad henny
with patrick mahomes at quarterback
including the postseason rob they've won
25 of 26.
right like i mean it's a juggernaut
because he finds a way
yeah the one thing that you you know
unfortunate for airbnb
of not getting a job that's another
topic we can ever get to
but you know keeping their coaching
staff intact
and all their players in tech i mean it
just
you know they they just kept everything
together
and that system that they have that andy
reid has just kind of developed a
culture
to let his players be themselves inside
of their systems
and anytime you're yourself in inside of
a system you just you're more
comfortable when you're more comfortable
you normally work at a higher rate and
that's the same thing as athletes and
you know you give a lot of credit to
andy reid uh to eric b enemy
uh for in and the hires up to be
for the kansas city chiefs of drafting
and tyreke heals because you know tiger
tyrant kill had that that red flag of
you know it should he be drafted where
should he be drafted but andy reed has
taken those guys on
he's given him a lot of love and they've
given him uh
one super bowl already and what the
possibility happened to
all right you mentioned eric the enemy
let's talk about it why do you think it
hasn't happened you know
that's a that's a great question um
you know it's it's a little unfortunate
um it is what it is you can't tell
uh a owner who to hire
that's one thing you can't do you can't
tell somebody who owns a business
that they have to hire a certain person
and you know unfortunately enough if you
look at this the
you know the process of where um
you know especially eb uh not having the
opportunity
because they're so good so he doesn't
really get to i mean even though he does
some virtual
he can't fly in on the week off um but
you know not having that opportunity to
have his own team is
it's kind of a it is sad to say it's sad
to see how
we the nfl has gone about hiring
um head coaches um i think they hire who
they're comfortable with
and who they maybe feel that
you know can can go
go with all their check marks in their
whatever their
their list is with what they want to see
as a head coach but how
how eric the enemy hasn't even though he
has a lot of opportunities to have
interviews
uh he had all those interviews and still
hasn't landed the job
is just unfortunate for
him and like he said at the press
conference earlier in the week that he's
not the poster boy
for coach is not getting a job he
doesn't want to be that guy
and you know so you give him credit for
that but you know
and luckily for them they haven't lost
him and they still have their whole
coaching staff
and you know it's going to be tough for
the template buccaneers
to to go against that off of the staff
yeah
and as he said he's not the poster boy
for this unfortunately it does keep
coming up
and for those who want to say we're
talking to rod woodson here well he's
not really calm please
that's not always true i mean he he does
call some
and and b it didn't prevent matt and
aggie from getting the bear's job as an
andy reid
assistant it didn't prevent doug
peterson from getting the eagles job
as an andy reid assistant so the idea
that
that should be the determining factor to
me is
is just kind of nuts i'm looking at your
list of career picks rod correct me if
i'm wrong you never
got tom brady i have the only patriots
quarterback you got was someone named
tom hodgson who i don't even remember
yeah i don't even know i think i played
against tom once
or twice maybe i don't remember
um yeah i mean tom was a baby right
you know when he when you know when i
was in the league and
you know i left to know four or three
excuse me after three season but i never
had the opportunity
to play and you love to play against the
best you know i played against
up to probably 13 hall of famers
and i'm including peyton in that because
he's going to be a hall of famer
but you know so it's it's always good to
play against guys like that i
don't but yeah i don't remember ever
getting tom um
never having that opportunity to do that
i ask you know thomas
how do you how do you get to 10 super
bowls
i i don't know we were talking about
that earlier and here
right here's some perspective babe ruth
got to 10 world series
far different era and he won seven
i mean this in the modern world to get
to 10
championships and now potentially win
seven out of ten is
i don't know i mean can you imagine kid
kids you know they want to play in the
national football league
and that's a great goal to have and then
tom brady like just raises the bar for
me
to say yeah you can play in the nfl if
you want to but
you know can you get the 10 super bowls
like the only person that can maybe get
to that point
is the guy that he's playing against
patrick holmes
and you gotta and then he has to be on a
good team for a long period of time for
you know almost 20 years
to get to that point so it's just it is
so hard what tom has done
in his career going from one team to the
next
and and to get that team
to the super bowl in his first year is
an amazing feat
you know this and i hope the fans know
this
but just to get to one is so hard to get
to
ten and then to win seven is just
it is mind-blowing before i let you go
rodney i appreciate the time here um i
i think i used to have a rule doing
radio all the time you're not allowed to
ask who's going to win until friday so i
apologize it is now friday
and you got stuck with this one who do
you like do i dare ask no you don't i
can make an argument for both and i said
at the very beginning of the [ __ ] right
when we first started talking i think i
can make an argument for the template
buccaneers of winning
the kim city chiefs to win the game but
i'm going to stick with the chiefs
because
it just it's hard for me to see them not
having a stretch in the game where they
don't score
two two touchdown two possessions having
two touchdowns three possessions in a
row having three touchdowns
and if the bucks and
you know and i love todd bowles but if
the bucks start playing a lot of
man-to-man
then i'm somehow tyree kill is gonna
find
you know i think jamal dean and i i
think he's played
he's played well but i think you know
he's they're going to find him
and because i really love carlton davis
but i think they'll find dean
and try to take some deep shots um so
um i'm sticking with kansas city i think
they'll just
i just can't see them the bucks just
outscoring them
even if it's a you know a shootout i
just can't see them
it happening i think mahome gets a
second i think andy reid
gets his second and they go back to back
i'm with you rod it is great to have you
on hall of famer
at the college football hall of fame the
pro football hall of fame
and a super bowl champion of the man who
is on the list of the top 100 to ever
put on a uniform rod have a great
weekend let's talk again soon
all right andrew take care you got it
man hey you watched all the way to the
end
thanks for that watch more right here